咱这节课讲类型片儿。
你说啥叫类型件？
为什么要什么类型？这几年咱经常听说啊说这是一部类型片儿。
或者还有人说这是一部反类型片啊吧？让他们说的云里雾里的。
呃，弄得很高大上一样。
其实类型片就是给电影分类嘛。
就是给电影分类。
分类一下，便于研究，便于寻找规律和方法。其实就这么一个简单的一个思路。
咱们这节课就来说一下。首先说一下啊这个类型片啊，它的分类方式。
没有明确的规定，说法也不太统一，怎么说的都有每本教材说的也不太一样。
先说一种大的笼统的分法啊，有些人说把电影可以分为商业片。
和文艺片。
有没有这种分法？
经常听到是吧？
那你说啥叫三片，啥叫文艺片？
你去问10个人，有9个半人说不明白这个事儿。
你即便是去问影视圈的人。
你问10个人，也有9个人。
说不明白啥叫上一篇，啥叫文一片。
大家直观上的感觉啊，就心里面的感觉就是那种好看的叫商业片，精彩的叫商业片，那种比较沉闷的，比较无趣的。
呃教我一片。
就说好看的叫商业片，不好看，那叫文艺片吧，烂片叫文艺片啊。
那肯定不是这么分的呀。
肯定不是这么分的。
还有一些人说啊，这个导演是拍文艺片的。
那就是他专门拍烂片呗。
专拍不好看的片子。
其实不是这么分的啊。
商业篇。
这么说吧，商业片是以观众为。
服务观众。
他比较功利。
他是为了让故事最精彩，让观众最最过瘾，是他这种片子的这个。
生产目的。
所以他奔得好看去的这个确实是。
然后文艺片呢那不是奔着不好看去的。
是奔着。
创作者的想法。创作者的。
这个这个这个构思是实现创作者。
呃，欲望的骗子。
呃，好不好看，那就随缘了，对吧？因为不是呃服务你观众去的。
那你说为什么要拍这种片子呢？
为什么要这个创作者要拍个片子自嗨呢？不服务观众的话。
他也是有目的的。
他往往是为了。
实验实践或者拓展。
一些技术领域。
技术手法。
表达方式。
叙事方式。
是为了这个目的。
我给你打个比方吧啊。
我之前给你们举过例子，我说这个这个创作者有点像这个这个。
汽车的设计师。
对吧。
你可以这么想。
商业片啊。
啊，就是量产车。
量产车什么目的？
服务消费者啊。
性价比。
这个驾驶体验安安全程度。
各方面的。
油耗。
知道吧。
他是全是为了这个消费者，为了这个驾驶者去考虑。
文艺片上就像概念车。
概念车显然不是为了上路，为了那个那个那个消费者服务的。
他是为了创作这个服务的。
创作者在概念车上实验一些新的技术，拓展一些新的领域。
尝试一些新材料、新技术、新能源。
新设计。
新思路。
是这个目的的。
所以其实啊你说设计概念车的那些设计师。
它一定是量产车设计的倍儿6啊。
对吧他必然是大师呀，才能再去拓展一下子。
我最烦哪一种啊？
就那一种小青年导演啥片子都没拍过，量产车一个也造不出来。但是说我是搞文艺片的，所以哎呀，我搞文艺，你搞什么文艺呀？
就文艺片成了烂片的避避风港了，你明白吗？就哦拍不好的就叫文艺片。
拍烂了的商业片就叫文艺片吗？不是这么想，你得有点追求啊。首先你必须是量产车大师了，手拿把掐了，你才去实验，才去探索。
对吧。
真正搞文艺片的啊，我没有搞过文艺片，我是搞商业片的。但我对真正搞文艺片的是非常尊重，非常敬佩的。为啥呢？是因为我们在这里搞商业片，很功利的在服务观众嘛，追求故事最精彩，追求观众最最最最爽，是我们的很功利的目标。
然后人家搞文艺片的人呢，就在替我们。
探索边界，寻找新的版图，他在探地图，你懂我意思吧？
我们当然其实应该尊重人家，敬佩人家。
这才是搞文艺片的。
而不是那种。
对吧啥片子都没拍过，然后片子拍不好，拍的很烂，然后觉得自己在搞文艺。
快算了吧，对吧？你是拍不好就说拍不好，不会就说不会你那个文艺片没有价值，你啥也没探索，你知道吗？或者是你用了一些别人文艺片里用，有些是仿文艺片，有这样的导演，他那文艺片也有点文艺调调，但你用的方法是别人文艺片里面用过的。
那用你用吗？
你探索什么玩意，人都探完了，这这个地图人探完了，你又去探一下，说自己搞。
所以在这里多说了这么几句，为什么？就我不希望咱们的呃。
咱们班的同学。
藏着一块文艺片的大旗啊，做自己的遮羞布。
不要这样。
你先把观众服务好，服务观众的片子就是商业片。因为观众就是顾客嘛，你服务他们就这就是商业，这本身就是商业了。
你就先把商业片做好，先把观众伺候好。
等你哪天功成名就。
这这个一肚子这个这个心得体会，无处触发，对吧？想要这个探索点新领域，发明点新方法就像。
人家。
那个那个。
詹姆斯卡梅隆。
你能说。
人家没探索新方法吗？
电影圈有多少新手段，新方法，发明专利是人家搞出来的，人家一直在探索，不耽误人家的片子好看。
你明白这个道理吗？
不耽误人家的片子好看，人家的片子拍的。
又好看又探索，又商业又文艺。
所以我多说这么几句，就是告诉大家。
少提这个话。
擦了就别提了，懂这意思吗？别提了，以后别说这种话。
别说搞文艺，就把把片子拍好。
服务好观众。
好吧。
所以说这显然不是我们说的。
电影的分类方法。
那电影还有怎么分类的？
还有一种分类。我们说视频网站上的种分类方法。
啊，咱们经常看到啊。
也是很多人理解电影类型是那么去理解的。我们说你打开一个视频网站，你看他他他怎么分，他往往啊，你看啊喜剧片。
一种类别动作片。
一种类别。
然后还有什么爱情片。
是吧也有吧。
还有什么恐怖片？
恐怖片后面还接个惊悚片。
是吧战争篇。
科幻片。
反正很多类吧很多类。
你说这种分类方式是怎么分的？
这种分类方式是怎么？
这种分类方式科学吗？
我告诉你这种方式是怎么分的啊？
他是从观看的角度。
从观众的角度分的。
这么分的。
你设想一下，你看电影这个东西啊其实是个很新的艺术形式，就出来100来年，对吧？在这100来年的发展过程中。
你回想一下这个小历史，你就了解了这个片子它是怎么来的。因为电影啊是在电影院放。
买票。
然后呢。
观众跑到电影院去看电影。
选择看什么电影呢？
还要通过这个电影的。
签名。
海报。
预告片。
和一些简单介绍来进行选择。
所以呢。
他在接受了一些初步的信息之后，他对这个影片就已经开始有一些期待。
有一些认知和期待。
这其实是什么呢？就是你这个片子传达出来的信息等于是给观众的一种承诺。
就造就了从宣传的角度和从期待的角度，慢慢两方面力量综合形成了这样一些信息化的分类。它其实是从观看承诺的角度分的。比如说我今天带着女朋友去看。
然后呢就会想看一个爱情片子。
爱情片、片名、海报、预告片、解样信息一一看你就知道哪个片子是爱情片了，不会有错的不会有错的。
对吧。
然后你就带女朋友进去看，这就是一种承诺，一种期待。然后进去之后，这个爱情片它一定是有浪漫元素的。
一定会让你感动。
一定会有男女主角的拥问。
这是度是最基本的承诺。
对吧你不可能就是说今天看一个海报，一个男的光着膀子，一身肌肉摆着这么一个姿势。然后你误认为这是一个爱情片，不可能的，他一定是个动作片儿，而且进去的之候，你一定要看他大。
他不打就不行。
对吧。
这就是一种从承诺的角度去去去分的。所以他其实是在观看。
电影的这个习惯中。
电影院的这个宣传中形成的这种分类。你说这种分类科学吗？
这个分类也不可学。
因为啥？因为他很多时候没法分。
对吧没法分。
一个喜剧片同时是一个动作片，这不太正常了。
成龙的片子全是喜剧加动作。
里面还有爱情。
是不是？
他往往都有啊。
你说周星驰的片子来。
百变星军。
喜剧科幻吧。
是不是？
那个那个呃功夫喜剧动作吧，美人鱼喜剧。
惊悚吧啊，恐怖哎，你说恐怖片和惊悚片啊，这两种类型我以前还研究过，那我老说那是恐怖跟惊悚，它是程度上的问题吗？一种比另一种更吓人吗？后来发现啊他分是怎么分的啊？就恐怖片啊。
他就分来自非自然的力量滚啊什么的，妖啊什么的，他就滑在恐怖片里面。
然后惊悚片呢就是比如杀人狂魔呀，那种连环杀人案呀，就人为的是惊悚的，超自然啊，它就归在恐怖片里边。爱情片也有爱情片还有一种爱以前那种爱情片，后面接一类分类叫情爱片。哎呀，妈呀。
情爱片就比爱情片啊更暧昧一点。
我也仔细观摩了一些片子，我我总结出来了，就是只亲嘴的算爱情片。
脱裤子的就叫情爱片了，他是这么分的。
然后这些分类全都卡不上的。
他最后扔一个大包打包。
叫人家剧情片有没有有没有这种分类剧情片。所以你说这种分类方式能科学吗？
对不对？能科学吗？就是。
你什么都分不了的，你个人归剧情片了，这是肯定不行的这就这种分类方式啊，它其实是。
应用于市场的。
针对于观众期待。
所以这种分类方式啊。
是海报的分类方式，我感觉更像是。
就是满足观众的期待。
你观众选择你这个片子想看什么？你给观众承诺了什么？
就是这种分类。
就好比你说那个。
我们说李连杰的片子。
只要出现李连杰的脸，那就一定是动作片。
这是你给观众的承诺。
所以你看他前几年拍了一个片子，跟文章的演什么父子情之类的嘛，反正就是完全不打的嘛，纯文艺的。
这个片子呃票房就不好，效果就不太好。
为啥呢？
他为啥要拍这个片子？他肯定是上了年纪打不动了，那想转型，而且当了这么多年演员，他肯定也是。
动作戏的演员都有这个这个执念，非要证明一下自己演技好。
可以演戏。
可以演文戏。
但其实啊。
他演文戏不成功，并不是演技不好，跟演技没有关系。
是因为你给观众的承诺已经固定了，观众去看你的时候就想看你打，这是你给观众的承诺，观众把你归在动作片里面了，就永远归在里面了。你这张脸出来。
就把你归在。
动作片里面了，顾人众怀着看动作片的心情去电影院，然后没有看到动作，他就一定不满意。
不是你演技不好。
而且也不用去转型。
对吧。
你就像你你。
你是奥利奥。
对吧然后你你你你觉得我奥利奥多牛啊，我这么有钱，我这么有技术，对吧？我要做轮胎。
对吧我不做饼干，我要生产一款轮胎。
我要跟米其林较一较劲。
有可能你做的轮胎也不错，因为你毕竟有钱，对吧？你收购一个好的轮胎厂，雇点牛逼的工程师也可能牛逼，但我们就是不买。
不用你的轮胎，就怕开着开着，中间裂开流出来一层白的奶油，你知道吧？就他对你的印象就是你就做饼干就挺好的。
不是说你不好，不是说你演技不好，他给观众一种承诺。所以说。
这种分类方式啊，从观众角度这种分类方式啊，更像是对海报的分类，也不算是对故事的分类。
我觉得也。
没用没用。
对，咱没用啊，我是这个意思啊，对咱写故事没用。
那咱今天讲类型片。
讲一个什么分类方式呢？我推荐给大家一种分类思路。
之前我也说过这个这个牛排。
叫。
布莱克斯奈德。
是这位好莱坞编剧他的一种分类方式，他有一套教材叫救猫咪。
我前面给大家讲过，对吧？
讲做人物的那里，我给大家讲过旧猫咪这个概念，它那套教材就叫救猫咪，它这个门派啊就叫救猫咪。
他是什么门派呢？
他算比较功利的那种，他下手挺狠的，下死手啊。
他认为所有的好莱坞影片可以分10个10个大类。
他可以分成10类。
然后呢呃给每一类找规律，硬性的说这这必须这么做必须这么做。
他是这么一个一个。
一个算是教育学家吧，剧本教育家。
很有名啊。
呃，他学生很多的在好莱坞很多的，得过很多大奖。
然后呃咱国内我也说过那个呃徐徐峥导演呀、宁浩导演啊，明显是他这个流派。
人家没明说啊，但咱能看出来，明显是这个流派。
这流派没什么不好，挺好的。但是我一直不推荐咱们现在去去研究它的教材，为啥呢？他适用于专业人士这么说吧。
就你已经很熟练了。
知道故事的各种套路了，然后再根据它的分类。
去进一步的强化自己的技巧，更规范自己的行为。
创作行为。
是这么一个作用。我认为啊。
当然有很多人骂他。
有很多人不同意救猫咪的观点啊，特别是那种老学究。
这就学院派啊是不太待见他的，认为他离经叛道。我说一下我的观点吧，我没有完全赞同就猫咪所有的理论。我也认为它的分类有些地方呢确实也不严谨。
不能完全涵盖。
但是老学究批判救猫咪的时候，我是果断的占救猫咪的。
我站队救猫咪的。
为啥呢？因为老学就批判他的更没有道理。
有很多传统观点认为他颠覆了一些。
莎士比亚、亚里士多德他们的理论。
觉得这个这个。
他有点哗众取宠。
这么说吧。
我们如果认认可剧本创作是一门技术。
那我们就要认可技术是在不断的发展和完善的。
就是文艺的人啊。
愿意从古。
就认为古代的人什么都是对的。
孔子说的什啥都对，对吧？这个这个上古的一些理论很玄妙，你慢慢去参悟他永远对。
就是有这种观点，但是理性的人啊，像像我们这种理科出身的人啊，我们不崇拜古，我们崇拜心。
越往后的东西，它是越。
越完善越先进的对吧？这是理性的认识。
你如果认可剧本是一门技术。
那就是新的比旧的好。
因为他在发展，他在完善。
我曾经跟中戏的一个老师一起喝茶的时候。
他也是那种老学究。
他就说啊这个。
莎士比亚如何如何，对吧？他就会说这个，然后就是说啊现在这些什么理论哗众取宠。
都不对，这这这个老祖宗的东西都给忘了。
这个这个。
但是呢我就觉得他很矛盾。我说那老师您认为剧本创作。
他是一门手艺吗？因为我们搞剧本的人都喜欢自称手艺人，自称匠人精神嘛，觉得这个词很啊很洋气，我们是匠人。
说老师，你觉得我们是匠人？
他说是呀，我们当然是匠人呀，我们有匠人的精神呀。
我说老师，既然咱们是匠人，是一门手艺。
那么为什么新的手艺会比旧的手艺差呢？
然后就掰扯不明白，老师就说对吧？那个中西的老师他就说呃古代的好。
然后我就问老师，我说那老师咱们这样去理解这个问题啊，既然他是一个咱是匠人，然后呢，剧本这个手艺是一门技术，对吧？
我们类比一下，我特别爱用比喻说服别人。我说我们类比一下老师。
假设啊。
您现在。
被蛇给咬了。
中毒了毒舌。
然后呢。
来了两个大夫。
一个是华佗穿越过来了。
对吧。
拿着一把刀。
说要刮骨疗伤。
一个呢。
是咱们出门右拐。
北京市长安区第三人民医院外科副主任。
刘大夫，咱也不知道叫什么名字，肯定不是什么大师是吧？刘大夫。
我说一个是医学界的泰山北斗吉的大叔大师啊。
一个呢。
无名小贝。
拿着一根针管说我来给你打一针。
我说老师，你现在腿很疼啊。
中了蛇毒了呀。
一个华佗，一个刘大夫。
你选谁？
老师陷入了沉默，想揍误我，我赶紧打个圆场说折过去。
啥意思呢？就是你既然认可剧本技术呃手艺，它是个技术。
那你就要认可他他在不断的发展，咱就要理性一点，对吧？刘大夫那一针绝对比华佗好使。
华佗在他的那个时代，有可能是。
一哥。
大牛。
这个毋庸置疑，他的地位毋庸置疑，对吧？但是咱们不能。
华佗对医学界的贡献当然也比刘大夫大。
但是他技术在发展，你明白这个意思吗？
就说句大逆不道的话，我认为易中天教授的学问有可能就是比孔子的学问大，明白这个意思吧？
就是他在发展。
不能认为。
这个这个剧本有一定的文艺性，咱们就去盲目的就说。
哎呀，古代的人说的都是有道理的。
所以说这个施奈德教授这是呃不是施耐德教授呢，说易中天教授说查了，斯奈德先生他不一定是教授啊，斯奈德先生这个救猫咪的理论他当然有纰漏，因为他也在探索嘛。
但是。
他一定是比较先进的。
一定是比较先进的。我们来可以研究一下，我们今天就来研究一下，我表明我的立场就是他如果跟老学球干起来了，我站他。
但是如果周下周周遭没有人，咱们今天没有外人，就咱们聊我跟你说救猫咪。
分成10个类型。
也不是特别严谨。
但是很有用，为啥呢？它不是从观众观看的角度分的。
明白吗？这个道理吧？就他不是按照。
这个这个你的观看习惯，你的海报习惯去分的，它是从故事。
从创作。
角度分的。也就是说从咱们自己的角度，从咱们编剧的角度，他去分我们有几有这10种创作思路。
哎，你这么理理解。
他这套东西它就是有用的，它是10种。
创作思路啊。
所以我从这个角度去理解救猫咪它这10个类型。
我觉得哎。
是有用的，因为它比这10种创作思路。
每种设了几条规矩，你再发现你的故事好，差不多是贴更贴这种类型的时候。
你可以有一个。
呃，行为准则。
不出缸。
不出杆，不出大错，就这样。
十类故事创作思路。我为什么说是故事创作思路？
就是我说的。
如果说这是10个类型的电影不够严谨。
明白这个意思吗？就说我说这是类型片啊，就如果说救猫咪的这10个类型是10个类型的电影啊，其实不够严谨。但说出说是10个类型的故事。
还是可以的。现在你理解不了，没关系，我们慢慢我们慢慢说，我先把它的10个类型啊。
我先把它的10个类型。
10个类型我们都来认识一下。
第一个类型。
叫金羊毛。
呃，旧猫咪这本书啊嗯咱还不知道谁翻的啊。
我我我不认识这个人。
咱客观的说啊，翻译的。
不不咋地，翻译不咋地，呃，我待会儿一个一个解释吧。好吧，翻译的确实不好。
第一类叫金羊毛。
第二类。
这个爱情。
然后第三类。
我们叫。
超级英雄。
第四类。
叫鬼屋。
然后。
侦探。
如愿以偿。
麻烦家伙。
便签仪式。
愚者成功。
最后一个叫。
被制度化。
啊，没有什么最后一个不最后一个啊，那顺序可调的。
就是这么几个类型。
十个类嘛，这是旧猫咪分的10个类。
我挨个给大家讲一下，咱这节课需要点耐心，好吧，需要点耐心。我给大家挨个说一下。
我说了啊，这个书啊翻译的不是很好，翻译的不是很好。
所以有点费解。
我挨个给大家解释一下。
金羊毛。
金耀王这个说法啊来自于他们希腊的一个呃。
童话传说就是一个王子到到去到处去寻找金羊毛。
找到那个金羊毛可以那啥的，可以继承王位之类的啊。
反正所以这类片子你可以理理解为寻宝片吧。
他是以寻宝片儿。
为蓝本的。
寻宝片为蓝本的，就是主人公去寻觅。
一个宝藏。
这么说吧，咱们中国的商业电影啊。
我感觉啊。
主流的里面。
这个类型肯定是最多的。
一定是最多的。
我感觉都有可能占到一半。
所有的公路片。
都属于金样毛。
所有的寻宝探宝类的就更不用说了啊。
寻宝探宝类的全属于这个这个类型啊。
各种盗墓的对吧？
然后。
抢银行的。
也属于金阳毛。
抢银行的骗子也属于金讶吗。
这有个侦探，抢银行不属于侦探，我待会儿告诉你为什么。
我没有仔细统计过。
粗略一估嘛啊。
中国的商业片主流商业片啊。
至少得有个小一半吧。
是金羊毛类型的片子。
这是嗯。
我为什么说这个救猫咪这套分类方式有点意思呢？值得参考呢？就是它是从讲故事角度去理解这个事儿，就是他是从咱们创作者写剧本的这个人的角度去理解这个事儿。
这种分类方式它不是别的。
分法它从故事角度。
寻宝类，那不就是最愿意给别人讲的那类故事吗？
童话故事里面最多的就是这种呀。
到一个圣山老林去去寻找什么宝藏。
寻宝类的故事。
有这么几个要素。
我再插一句啊，就是说不管什么类型。
都跳不出。
我最早给大家讲的。
要素也好。
私幕式也好。
序列也好，都跳不出那个框，明白这个意思吗？
他都是按照那套方式写。
但是他会有几个自己的重点。
需要捏死的。
就是说这种片子也是那八要素，也是那十序列。但是有几个点它必须转的死死的，才能让这种片子。
好看。